Al Pacino
okay so let's talk about Al Pacino right
the man the myth The Legend So he
recently was in hot water because he had
a kid with a 29 year old hottie he's 83
his at the time his um girlfriend was 29
he decided to have a kid with her and I
think women get mad about this because
they kind of show how younger women can
just yeah they can compete right for the
top men he can still do this at that age
women will still do it however you do
get the problem with gold digging
now I can't say I'm shocked that this
happened Al Pacino's girlfriend Nora
alfala reportedly files for full
physical custody of their
three-month-old son so oscar-winning
actor Al Pacino 83 and his girlfriend
Nora
alfala 29 have reached a custody
agreement for their three-month-old son
Roman despite previous breakup rumors
which the couple denied court documents
reveal that Roman will predominantly
stay with alfala with Al Pacino granted
reasonable
visitation rights both having joint
legal custody
alfala initiated the filing process and
Pacino confirmed his biological relation
to Roman media reports initially
suggested a separation but Pacino's
spokesperson refuted this emphasizing
that the couple is still together and
collaborated on a custody plan recent
reports hint that their romantic
relationship while sharing moments
together with alfala seeking more
significant monetary support the couple
was spotted dining together in LA on the
same day the legal papers were filed
their relationship officially announced
in April 2022 and alfala is credited as
a producer for Pacino's upcoming for
um and I'll follow as credited as a
producer for Pacino's upcoming movie
Billy Knight
guys we've just seen this play out too
many times women are women you know it
says reasonable custody like when are
women reasonable ever now it's so funny
because I realize how extreme I sound to
like people that haven't been red pilled
yet I thought about this the other day a
lot of stuff I say like women aren't
reasonable we just always want more and
more and more and we'll always just try
to procure resources from males this
sounds you know evil whatever
um but
it's just kind of how women are and have
always been you know we have certain
Trends you know women are individuals
some act differently but we seem to fall
follow certain patterns and really the
patterns they don't lie
um so am I shocked that she got the kid
and at three months now they're they're
sort of on the way to separation
and is it shocking to me that she wants
more of a monetary contribution
not at all now uh what the what the
right is gonna do is say oh well he
should have just got a good woman like
wouldn't it be better if he got a older
woman or a more accomplished woman no
women are women
like it's really a roll of the dice it's
based on how we feel so if the woman
feels like she's into you for a lifetime
then she's gonna be a good woman but to
act like we're these like logical
creatures now you're turning us into men
we're not logical or reasonable we just
feel things and how we feel that day is
how we Act and you know you might get
lucky you get a good woman who never
feels that way but I know too many
stories of women being really great
wives and mothers until one day they're
not until one day they go off the rails
uh you know I mean we've seen women
pastors and preachers they start only
fans
uh women act one way and we're Master
manipulators you know what I mean it's
just uh
now oh I know what you're thinking Pearl
aren't but men manipulate too oh no
I mean that you saw that one that woman
earlier that convinced that man that six
kids were his
you think a guy is Cape I mean men get
caught dming other girls
like men get caught men can't even get
away with the cheating we're like the
CIA of phones you know so it's like okay
the men they can't even cheat in peace
but us women figure out a way to
convince men that biological kids are
not theirs
women you know I and this might be
cynical
but you know there's negative parts of
male nature too you know if there was
okay okay I'll give you guys this if men
you know had no legal restraints I think
a lot of guys would kill somebody you
know I mean another guy
I mean I mean I think they they estimate
that 10 of our ancestors got murdered
you know but we have systems in place
that say Hey guys if you act on your
male nature
um you're gonna get punished you know I
think women will too right I mean
men and women with killing like women
love to kill their children so I don't
now you I know I know how this sounds
you're like Pearl isn't that cynical
well one out of three of us has had an
abortion so it's like I mean I don't
know what to tell you and I didn't I
didn't come in with these opinions but
then you just start looking at the
patterns and you're like there really
are patterns for certain women in
society
um and even if you look at it's
interesting in history you can look at a
lot of like peasants wives seem to kind
of there were systems to keep them from
acting out right but a lot of these
King's wives were in history
sorry ladies you know because they're
around all the other high-value guys and
it's the same thing and I think the
problem is we keep telling everybody
that we're so special and unique and as
people we're really not that special
we're unique we're just people you know
we have a nature and the problem is we
equip women
um to act on the worst part of our
nature which is that we're emotional
we're feelings first we're never happy
and a lot of times we get greedy
men are a lot more thankful they're a
lot more like happy to be there thankful
and just like content
ah sorry ladies it's why you know men
will go to a basketball game and women
want to watch the soap operas women like
the highs and the lows men you know like
the camaraderie the teamwork I
anyways um yeah so I just think we need
I really don't see I really would love
to see traditional marriage come back
but I just don't think they're gonna do
that I I just don't see it coming back
until we change the systems because the
problem is even a religious woman can be
influenced by the media even a religious
woman can be influenced by your friends
even a religious woman can be influenced
by her peer group women are women and
that's that's the problem is we keep
telling men that women aren't women oh
you can find a special woman who's not a
woman no she's still a woman and you
know there's women that are higher risk
and lower risk like I'd imagine
and only fans model with a chest tattoo
I'd say that's much higher risk than the
Virgin bride right but even the Virgin
brought you know I've heard horror
stories you know it's so funny I've
heard horror stories from men that
married virgins I've heard it all uh you
can't really go to school to do what I
do I've interviewed so many hundreds of
people you know I've had consultations
with guys that tell me I married the
Virgin bride and it wasn't what you what
what you say it's cracked up to be and
he's right
because women are women there's lower
risk and there's higher risk but women
are women
um and again we're just brainwashed into
saying female nature is so amazing and
so special and it's like from God and
we're so smart and
not really uh you know I mean they're
smart women there's lower risk women but
they're still women and there's a reason
that in history women really weren't
believed it wasn't for no reason and
that's that's the biggest you know
that's what I've learned a lot of times
there's a reason for things people
always look at history like it's just
these oppressive mean people but a lot
of times there's reasons that we did
what we do now does that mean everything
would work today I don't know the path
moving forward but I think the first
step is acknowledging female nature and
putting in policies that protect men
from female nature and really protect
ourselves from our own nature because a
lot of these women are gonna leave and
have horrible lives so it's like maybe
maybe we should we should even protect
our like it's in our own best interest
that time but
you know um let me know what you guys
think uh maybe I'm just too extreme I
don't know
um like the video and guys especially
like the video on your way out and
really I think none of these problems
would have happened if women didn't vote
you know let's repeal the 19th baby get
yourself a shirt today a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt at the audacity Network dot
store like the video on your way out
subscribe to to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time